Lế hội văn hóa ẩm tực, món ngon sài gòn tourist group 2 hủ chăm 2 mì sau sĩ ra tại thành phố Xí Minh,
với thi mô lớn, quý tụ hơn năm 2 mòn ăn từ khắp bà miền.
Lế hội văn hóa ẩm tực, món ngon sài gòn tourist group 2 hủ chăm 2 mì sau có chủ đề kết nối tình 3 vàng hóa ẩm tực Việt Nam.
Rồi sài gòn tourist group tổ chức tại khu xú lịch văn thánh thành phố Xí Minh.
Chương trình quý tụi 5 người đơn vị khách sản khu xí dưỡng,
nhà hàng bố đến năm sau thục hệ thống sài gòn tourist group trên tòan quốc,
phố Xí Minh, đối tác xú lịch, lưỡng hành.
Sự kiện không chỉ dừng lại ở việc dưới thiệu món ăn,
bố xanh hàng đều tại hiện một phần đặc trưng bùng miền từ nguyên liệu,
cách xế biến đến cách trình bài.
Nguyên thăm sự có thể giễ sản bất gập các món quan thuộc,
nhiều đặc sản địa phương ý phổ biến, bố n chỉ có tại nơi sản sốt.
Vì tập trung số lượng lượng món ăn trong cộng một không d'an dút người thăm quan có thể chả nghiệp đang giả hội vị trong thời gian ăn.
Không d'an lễ hội được tổ chức theo nhiều khu vực,
gắn với tình chủ đề của thế.
Hú trở quay bố xí gần cộng định biến phụ
tán hiện lại không khi mua bàn trình thống với các sân hàng măng phòng cách một mặt.
Hú trở nội đặt cảnh gà văn thánh,
là một trong những diễm dính về không dân.
Tại đây, các tiền và quay hàng được sắp sếp theo mô hình trở nội miền tây
tạo tránh gi ik gần với tự tiếp.
Vì chỉ này cũng thận tiện cho việc xí chuyện bằng mê chô.
Khách thăm quan có thể vừa xế tải các nhà gà và tiếp cận lễ hội ngành trống,
với chi vì thấp hơn sau với các phương tỉnh cá nhân.
Bù bánh dân dân dân tập trung nhiều lại mánh đặt trưng của các phù miền,
với sự đa dạng về quyền liệu và cách chế biến.
Mài việc thử tức, hách thăm quan còn có thể thăm dà trẻ nghiệm làm mánh tại chỗ,
dưới sự hông dẫn của các nghỉ nhân.
Các chiến nghiệm thật trình thống được bố xí xe kể trong không dàn lễ hội,
có phần tải hiện mối cạnh văn hoa gắn với ẩm thực,
thay bị chỉ tập trung vào yếu tổ ăn uống đơn thần.
Bình cạnh ẩm thực, lễ hội tổ chức nhiều hạt động mũ trở nhằm tăng trẻ nghiệm trong người tham dự.
Hù lần người trên thống cho phép khách thăm quan trực tiếp quan sát và thăm dà một số công đạn thù công như làm mũ,
trang mánh, hòa động này giúp người xem nhiều só hơn về quy trình tạo ra sản phẩm,
cũng như ra chỉ của các người trên thống.
Năm này, lễ hội có thêm sự thăm dà của một số xanh hàng quốc tế,
trong đó có đại dịnh từ khá lăng và thay lăng,
giúp hó phần làm đàn sản trẻ nghiệm của thực khách.
Với quy mũ lần, cách tổ chức thời trụ để só giảng và đàn sản trẻ nghiệm,
lễ hội tích tục là một trong những sự kiện ẩm thực thú đồng đồng,
mùi dân và dù hách tại thành phố Chính Mình.
Sự kiện diễn ra từ ngày 20, 2018,
mở cửa phục vụ công chúng từng với lắm đến 20 hài dơ mối này.